[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight and happy Friday all the
good stuff happens on Friday the news
stacks up and we finally get answers and
we have some tonight
after a year of research and interviews
the House Intelligence Committee has
finally completed its investigation into
that Russian meddling during that Oh 16
election you've been hearing so much
about the final report is out it's more
than 200 pages long here's the headline
investigators found no evidence of
collusion or coordination of any kind
between the Russian government and the
Donald Trump for president campaign none
so that's bad news we other cable
channels they probably ought to
apologize for the entire last year of
their programming but obviously don't
hold your breath
but to the rest of us there is really no
surprise here because there was never
any evidence of collusion it was always
a fantasy by the way the report does not
offer any evidence that the Russian
government directed the hacking of the
DNC servers or John Podesta's gmail
account either to this day though no one
ever says it no one has ever come up
with any proof that that happened
despite the fact that we're all
apparently required to believe that it
happened or else were Russian agents
ourselves but whatever there's not a lot
knew about the Trump campaign in this
report but there is quite a bit about
how Washington actually works consider
former Director of National Intelligence
Jim clapper for years clapper was one of
the most powerful intelligence chiefs in
the world now he's a cable news Schauder
and a political activist he's also a
prolific liar according to today's
reports in sworn testimony to Congress
under oath clapper claimed that he never
discussed the steel dossier with anyone
in the press that's untrue the report
reveals that clapper whispered to CNN
about the steel dossier and months later
of course the network hired him as a
contributor he still has one yesterday
Jim Comey told our friend Bret Baier
that clapper encouraged him to discuss
the dossier with the president that
briefing was later used by CNN and other
media was to justify reporting on the
dossier and so on in the circular
fashion we've been watching for the last
year in other words the whole thing was
a setup from the beginning no one ever
really believed the dossier was true
cared if it was true it was always just
a tool designed to hamstring an
administration that permanent Washington
opposed from day one Trump was on to
this actually from the beginning he
couldn't really explain it but he could
smell it which is his one great talent
and he was right
of course he was attacked mercilessly
for suggesting the so called Intel
community might not be on the level how
dare he do that they Yelp done CNN
they're public servants they dedicated
their lives to keeping you safe blah
blah blah blah blah actually they're
just people some of them are great
people some of them are rotten and
unethical some would gladly use leaks
deception and innuendo to reverse the
results of an election most people
understand this and that's why the
phrase deep state is suddenly part of
the public conversation John Brennan is
part of the reason by the way Brennan is
the former head of the CIA and like Jim
clapper he's an accomplished and
enthusiastic liar like clapper he's
begun his second career as a political
activist almost immediately after
today's report was released and long
before he could have actually read the
report
Brennan denounced the entire thing as
meaningless he then said this on Twitter
directly to the president quote the
special counsels findings will be
comprehensive and authoritative stay
tuned mr. Trump he added an ellipsis
just to make it extra ominous which it
was okay so the longtime chief of a
shadowy intelligence agency is warning
the democratically elected president of
our country that something bad is about
to happen to him apparently because John
Brennan has inside knowledge the rest of
us don't but don't let that bother you
don't get paranoid or anything don't buy
any of those nutty conspiracy theories
about the deep state everything is fine
just be sure to obey the permanent
government in Washington or else goons
like John Brennan will crush you Terry
turkey is former deputy assistant
director of the FBI's counterterrorism
division while he Hemingway's the senior
editor at The Federalist and they both
join us at the top of the show tonight
first to you Molly what do you make of
this you read the report what's the
takeaway well this is interesting they
found that after a year of rigorous
investigation there's no actual evidence
of treasonous collusion between from and
the Russian government that's probably
not very surprising what they did show
was that there's quite a lot of
collusion at the highest levels of
government to cook
and propagate a narrative of Russian
collusion we'd already learned from this
committee about the FISA abuse at DOJ
where they used a research document
bought and paid for secretly by Hillary
Clinton and the Democratic national
community committee to secure a wiretap
on a trump campaign affiliate and then
you picked up on this other thing that
is interesting James clapper gave
contradictory testimony under oath about
what he was leaking to CNN and that is
interesting the whole thing that got
everything going was this briefing of
president-elect Trump supposedly about
the dossier we later learned it was only
about one salacious part of the dossier
and this was highly placed this was this
was well sourced obviously it when it
looks like it went to clapper or someone
close to him and learning that this was
all done that Comey was asked to brief
president-elect Trump on this dossier
and that this was done because CNN
needed a news hook in order to justify
writing about a dossier that is a very
interesting detail to learn and should
put a lot of the coverage that we've
seen for the last 15 months an entirely
new light well I mean Terry you sure you
spent a lot of your life working for the
federal government a law enforcement
agency that has intelligence components
to it the credibility of the agencies
I'm sure important to you it's important
to me as an American citizen none of
this seems to help I mean if there's no
collusion at the bottom of all of this
then all of this is starting to look
very political and that's bad for the
way citizens feel about their government
isn't it absolutely and when you look at
this the real dangerous part of this and
the part that should scare every one of
us you just named them the the heads of
the major intelligence and investigative
agencies the United States the CIA the
FBI the NSA all of these people at the
top appear to have had just one goal in
mind and that was to be anti-trump and
to make trouble for him after he became
the president I think it's really
interesting that all of this idea of
unmasking for example didn't really
start up until after he became elected
and I think that everybody thought and I
think Molly and you and I would not even
be sitting here today and talking had
Hillary Clinton won the election and
Donald Trump lost I think this whole
thing about Russian collusion would have
vanished somewhere but really that was a
shock to the system and so something had
to be done because they
had to make sure that they the impudent
Trump's so that they could maybe be on
the way to regain some sort of power
again I really think we have reached a
point in America where we don't like to
talk about this and we weren't supposed
to talk about it for years but the
Democratic Party is important it's part
of our two-party system but it has gone
so far to the left that you're seeing
all of these kinds of practices and
things going on that make you think that
maybe the Democratic Party is the party
that has a real problem with with people
who have penetrated it maybe the
Russians have maybe the Cubans have
maybe the Chinese have but there's a
real there's a lot of indicators here
that all of these arrows keep going back
in that direction and they're up to
their eyeballs in all of these things
that we're told were were supposed to
make Trump look bad and look like him
like he was concluded colluding with the
Russians which which is not the case
right well maybe they just don't believe
in democracy and so in the results don't
don't go their way they try to undermine
them I'm really bothered by this tweet
in the in the larger behavior of John
Brennan I don't understand why former
CIA director would send out a tweet in
effect threatening the president and
suggesting that he knows something about
the mauler investigation of the rest of
us a don't it's almost designed to
convince the rest of us the deep state
is real it does almost seem like it was
designed that way it's also been a
pattern for him I don't know if you
remember about a year a year and three
months ago when Donald Trump was
critical of intelligence agencies and
intelligence community in general a lot
of people said you better stop it or
they will get back at you and then
shortly thereafter this briefing
occurred it was immediately leaked to
CNN and the entire Russian narrative
really got going and this was a hysteria
that has caused quite a bit of emotional
and financial impact on the United
States including the setting up of a
special counsel and and you know we
learned this week that James Comey did
admit that he had been sharing
classified information multiple people
he claims it's not a leak when he shares
classified information with people for
some reason that makes sense to him but
for the rest of us would be criminal
leaking and that that this is Wolf's
Comey clapper Brennan Brennan's highly
partisan tweets and highly threatening
tweet they're ominous and then they leak
the transcript of the president's
conversations with foreign leaders
i I just Terry want to end with you
since again you spent a lot of your life
working at high levels of government I
you don't seem like a conspiracy nut or
a crazy person just the opposite I don't
think that I am but are you starting to
think that there is a kind of loose
conspiracy of intent among permanent
bureaucrats in Washington it seems that
way I think there is and I think that
unfortunately a lot of the dogma and the
ideology Tucker of the 1960's where we
were dealing with revolutionaries out in
the street I think a lot of that has now
found its way inside government all
these years later and I know people are
going to say oh wow there's an old
communist chaser but that's what it
looks like to me it looks like the the
words that were used then are the words
that are used now people may not realize
it but if you look at the prairie fire
you know ideology written by Bill Ayers
and several other people back in the
1970s the chief strategy to deal with
infiltrating and then and then
overthrowing eventually the United
States government is called the
resistance and if you go into the detail
of that 181 pages if you really want to
the words come back and have a real
strong meaning and a real ring because
they're everything we hear today fascism
racism Native American injustice all of
these things are back and now they're
back but the people that are using them
are in a political party I think behind
the scenes trying to do everything they
can to convert us in the direction of
socialism and our intelligence agencies
that are that are supposed to protect us
seem to be part of that now the baby
boom took over so none of this just
surprises that terry molly thank you
both very much